TOWNSEND: Welcome, ladies and gentlemen, to
the Council on Foreign Relations meeting with
director of national intelligence, my good
friend Jim Clapper. This meeting is part of
the Kenneth A. Moskow Memorial Lecture on
homeland security and counterterrorism, which
honors the memory of Kenneth Moskow, a long-time
CFR member, with a distinguished career in
the intelligence community. Further details
on his life and professional accomplishments
can be found in the booklet of today's meeting.
I'd like to extend a special welcome to Keith
Moskow and to the family and appreciate your
support and your being here today.
So, usual format. I'm going to begin by asking
the questions and then we will make sure I
have left time for members to ask their questions.
You spent a lot of time testifying on Capitol
Hill in the last couple of days. Last week
you said that when a final accounting is done,
2014 will be the most lethal year for global
terrorism in theforty-five years that the
data has been kept: 13,000 attacks, 31,000
killed. There seemed to be a little, in Washington
terms, kerfuffle with the secretary of state's
statement on the same issue. Why don't you
speak to that.
CLAPPER: Well, I think the secretary talked
about—I had occasion to speak with him afterwards
and I think he was thinking of a different
context, which of course, context doesn't
lend itself to soundbites in Washington, D.C.
And I think what he was thinking about was
the more cataclysmic case in point of the
case with the Cold War. And he's right. In
that context we are a safer country.
But I was looking at more the here and now,
what happened in 2014 and kind of what we
project out in the next year, which is the
framework of normally our threat assessment.
So just two different contexts, I think.
TOWNSEND: So aboutten days ago the president
hosted the Countering Violent Extremism summit
at the White House. There were state and local
partners, nonprofit partners, international
partners, in the course of two and a half
days.
The president sort of steadfastly refused
to call it Islamic extremism, but the current
threat is not Buddhists or Christians. How
do you define a threat?
CLAPPER: Well, the way I look at this and
the way I think about it is, the president
has a much larger agenda. He is speaking to
1.6 billion Muslims around the world. We in
the intelligence community are focused on
the very, very small, way less than 1 percent
of that 1.6 billion Muslims. So our proclivity
would be to call these people what they call
themselves, you know;IS is the Islamic State.
So I think our purposes, our missions there,
if you will, are a little bit different, but
in intelligence we need to be as accurate
as we possibly can and call things in many
cases what they call themselves. And so that's
our focus, as opposed to his, which is much
broader.
TOWNSEND: Let's talk for a minute. One of
the great threats and concerns here in the
United States has been about foreign fighters.
In testimony, you referred to more than 20,000
foreign fighters, 3,400 of whom are Westerners,
150 of whom are Americans. We've seen cases
of Americans trying to go over, women. There
is a case right now of the British schoolgirls
who folks are trying to find.
CLAPPER: The case here in Brooklyn.
TOWNSEND: The case here in Brooklyn. Despite
airstrikes, why are the numbers of foreign
fighters not just continuing but, according
to the head of the National Counterterrorism
Center, they're increasing?
CLAPPER: They are, and it' a great concern.
And I was just in Europe a month or so ago,
in fact in Paris and Brussels, and it is very
much on the minds of European countries. The
actual number I quoted in open testimony with
the Senate Armed Services Committee last Thursday
was about 180 Americans.
Now when I say that, that is those who have
attempted to go and never got there, those
that went and got killed, those that went
and fought and went someplace else, and those
who have come back, which is a much lesser
number. So when you think of our population,
315 million, whatever it is, and a relatively
small number of people in contrast to the
European countries, where it is overwhelming
in terms of their ability to monitor and surveil
these people.
So it is a tremendous problem, you know. The
question is why, you know, what is the attraction.
I don't think there's any single explanation
for it. There's a combination of factors,
emotional, ideological, whatever. But this
is a very bothersome concern and of course
it gives rise somewhat to probably the most
frequent threat that we here worry about,
which is homegrown violent extremists.
ISIL particularly is very slick, very sophisticated,
proselytizing and recruiting, and they are
very astute users of social media. So this
is a challenge for us as it is in Europe.
TOWNSEND: Director, you mentioned the small
number that come back. What do you estimate,
of 150 Americans, foreign fighters, what number
of them do you believe have gone and actually
come back?
CLAPPER: On the order offorty or so, and
many of those are not—don't have nefarious
purposes. We have since found they went for
humanitarian purposes or some other reason
that don't relate to plotting. In fact, at
this point we are not aware of any of these
people who returned who are engaged in plotting.
TOWNSEND: But there are plenty of people here,
and those listening, I suspect, who are saying,
but wait a minute. If you know they went,
how is it they were able to come back, and
should that be a concern to us.
CLAPPER: Well, if they come back and they
are not involved in plotting or don't have
a nefarious purpose, then that's their right
and privilege as American citizens to come
back.
TOWNSEND: Now we've heard in the past about
another group, not ISIS but the Khorasan group
in Syria, an al-Qaeda affiliate, being a direct
threat to the United States. What is the status
of our efforts against the Khorasan group?
CLAPPER: Well, we are watching them as carefully
as we can. This is an expatriate group that
found its way from Afghanistan, Pakistan.
In fact, Khorasan refers to a region there.
And they are very focused on plots against
the West and then particularly us. So we're
watching them very carefully.
TOWNSEND: Let me ask you while on the subject
of Syria, is it, in your judgment, possible
to defeat ISIS in Syria without also targeting
Assad?
CLAPPER: Well, I think the way we are thinking
about it now is, what is the priority. And
the priorityfor us right now is ISIL, acknowledging
the fact that at some point Assad has got
to go because, as particularly many in Europe
feel, that the magnet for all this extremism
that has found its way to Syria is because
of him.
So I think there's certainly recognition of
that but I think the focus from a priority
standpoint right now is on ISIL.
TOWNSEND: But that's not necessarily the view
of our Arab allies, who, while they are committed
to the air effort, if we want them to contribute
ground forces, want Assad to go and want us
to target him as well. So how do you keep
the coalition together while the U.S. may
want to do it sequentially when your Arab
allies want you to do it at the same time?
CLAPPER: Well, this is probably, you know,
this fits gets into the policy arena and the
metaphor I like to use is that the intelligence
community is down in the engine room shoveling
intelligence coal and the people on the bridge
decide things like that.
(LAUGHTER)
TOWNSEND: That was an elegant avoidance of
the question. Let's talk about FSA for a minute.
Clearly there has been a policy decision to
train FSA. Ray Odierno, the chairman, the
Army Chief of Staff, last week told Wolf Blitzer
that the Army, the U.S. military will begin
to train the FSA in March.
CLAPPER: By FSA you mean Free Syrian Army?
TOWNSEND: That's right. The Syrian opposition.
Are we confident about vetting in terms from
an intelligence perspective those that we
are training so that they won't have to be
a threat...
CLAPPER: Well, the challenge here is going
to be the time it's going to take to recruit,
vet and then train people, and then get up
to a sufficient military center of mass, if
you will, to have real impact. So the issue,
at least for me as I watch this, is the time
it's going to take to get sufficient horsepower,
firepower, however you want to characterize
it, that would have a significant impact on
the battlefield.
TOWNSEND: Now let me ask you about, you know,
the consequence of this five year-plus civil
war that's been going on, it's the largest
number of refugees and internally displaced
persons since World War II.
CLAPPER: Right. You read my oral statement
very carefully.
TOWNSEND: From a counterterror perspective,
I worry that's also the largest recruiting
pool you could possibly create for the future
of ISIS and al-Qaeda. How do we position ourselves
to try and thwart that?
CLAPPER: That isa great concern and is something
that doesn't get a lot of attention. There
are something on the order of 11.4 million
displaced people just from Syria alone, which
has literally flooded the adjacent countries.
This is a huge strain on the likes of Lebanon,
Jordan and Turkey, for example. And so as
best they can to try and cope with this onslaught
of refugees, and of course you can imagine
some of the conditions, living conditions,
which of course just gives rise to—creates
the environment for recruiting.
And so that's a great concern that I have
and it is hard for us to reach directly into
these refugee camps. I will say, though, that
one of the things that I think we have awakened
to is the need for a very robust effort at
the counter narrative, and this is particularly
so with ISIL, since they are very, as I said
before, very slick, very sophisticated at
appealing to, you know, a fairly large segment
of people, as they will in these refugee camps.
TOWNSEND: So to use your analogy, you are
shoveling the intel into the system below
deck. Is this an issue that the policymakers
are grappling with, the refugee camps and
the potential future for recruitment?
CLAPPER: Well, I think the policy apparatus,
the policy-making community in Washington
is dealing with this whole potpourri, this
myriad of issues in Washington. It always
interests me, you know, when I watch TV and
how simple things are, and somehow in the
situation room they ain't so simple. And this
is the kind of dilemma we have today, the
diversity of crises and challenges we have
around the world.
I've been, in one capacity or another, in
the intel business forfifty-two years and
I don't remember a time when we had been beset
by more crises and challenges around the world,
and a diversity of these crises and challenges
than we have today.
TOWNSEND: So we can't sort of talk about Syria
without also talking about Iran. Senator Reed,
during your testimony, asked you the question
if nuclear negotiations fail, if we were to
intervene against Assad in Syria, what is
your assessment based on the intelligence
about the likelihood Iran might become more
aggressive against U.S. interests, whether
in Iraq or around the world.
CLAPPER: Well, I honestly don't know, you
know. People want clairvoyance, you've got
to spend a lot more money on intelligence,
I guess. I don't know, you know, what they'll
do if there's not a deal. I know they want
one very badly because they want—in the
worst way, want sanctions relief.
We are at a very delicate time right now with
respect to negotiations, and so I don't know
how that will come out. I'm not sure just
what that would do if there isnot a deal,
how that would—what impact that would have
on Iranian behavior. I don't know that they
would change their basic policies, particularly
as they pertain to regional influence. I don't
think it would change it much.
I think they would continue to do as they
have, and clearly they are—they have big
interest in the outcome of things in Iraq.
They very much consistently wanted a Shia-friendly
government that they can influence in Baghdad.
And so that will continue.
I think they will continue sustaining their
surrogates, Hezbollah. They have an interest
in Syria. So I don't see that changing, regardless
of the outcome of the negotiations. In fact,
I made the point to Senator Reed, for whatever
reason those are kind of separate and distinct
right now. They really haven't made the connection.
TOWNSEND: And I found that interesting. The
word you use is they have compartmentalized,
right? The problem is, when they care—we
saw during the Iraq war when we had U.S. troops
there, they were not the least bit shy when
they didn't like U.S. policy, about targeting
our military. But you don't think they will
get more aggressive against us?
CLAPPER: The issue for them, for the Iranians,
is sustaining their control, influence, over
the Shia militia. There are somewhere in the
neighborhood of seven or eight major—there
may be more, but the major Shia militia organizations
in Iran, and I think as long as the Iranians
perceive that we are doing what comports with
their objective, which is eliminate ISIL,
as long as we are on sort of a parallel course
there, they will do what they can to control
the militias.
And of course they have long harbored resentment
of the U.S. presence. They certainly did when
we were there and they do now and they, you
know, look at us as—their rhetoric is that
we are occupiers. And so it's a concern of
mine as to whether while we think we've messaged
the Iranians about the militias, that's not
to say that they have perfect command and
control over all—they, the Iranians, have
perfect command and control over the activities
of each militia or each militia member.
TOWNSEND: So speaking of the groups that the
Iranians influence and control, let's move
south to Yemen. Was it an intelligence failure
or did the intelligence community predict
the Houthi takeover of Yemen?
CLAPPER: Well, another old saw of intelligence.
You know, the first week in intelligence school
you learn there are only two conditions in
life. There is policy success or there is
intel failure. There is no other condition
in life.
(LAUGHTER)
No, it wasn't a failure, and anyone who is,
you know, remotely acquainted with the history
of politics in Yemen and its history understands
that the governmental institutions there have
always been very, very fragile. And so as
the Houthis expanded their area of influence
and as they infiltrated, particularly in the
Sanaa, infiltrated into the ministries of
the government, infiltrated the intelligence
and security organizations, it was pretty
clear where things were going and it was just
a question of time.
TOWNSEND: And regarding timing, it has been
said to me it was sort of the dog that caught
the bus unexpectedly, but it fell, that the
Houthis gained power more quickly than...
CLAPPER: Well, yes, that's a great question.
And here's where the Houthis and the ISIL
have something in common. When it comes time
to govern, they find out that that is not
inconsequential undertaking, that's a different
proposition. And the Houthis are discovering
that in Yemen. All of a sudden now, you know,
like it or not they are responsible for the
economy there, which is in extremis. And similarly,
ISIL is straining to provide governance and
municipal facilities in a place as large as
Mosul, for example. So these are two common
phenomena that both these groups are experiencing.
TOWNSEND: So let me ask you, there was a recent—there
was a development this morning. The Houthi
had taken captive a senior Saudi diplomat.
He's been in custody for some time. They just
released the Saudi diplomat this morning.
Are we to read into that...
CLAPPER: Being held by the Houthis or by AQAP?
I thought he was held by the AQAP.
TOWNSEND: My question to you, what are we
to read from the release? If he was released
by AQAP—I think you are right, I'm sorry—are
we to be concerned? Should we be concerned
about Saudi interaction with extremist groups
in Yemen?
CLAPPER: Well, I don't know. I honestly don't
know what to read into that. We will have
to sort that out to determine the significance.
Normally, you know, AQAP, AQAM, these groups
will use kidnapping as a way of raising revenue.
So exactly what they had in mind there I don't
know. We will have to sort that out a bit.
TOWNSEND: Well, we know the Saudis have had
an incredible relationship and intelligence
insight into AQAP. They have helped us thwart
attacks. They have been incredible allies,
and so clearly they have some insight...
CLAPPER: Well, they do, and of course they
are very concerned about the rise of the Houthis,
a Shia group, which has certainly relations
with and gets support from the Iranians. And
so in the minds of some, this maybe conjures
up another chapter of Hezbollah. I don't think
that's the case. I think the Houthis are much
more independent than that, but the Saudis
classically have been very concerned about
the Houthis right on their border.
And so the emergence of the Houthis as a dominant
political force in Yemen is a matter of great
concern. I would emphasize what you said,
Fran, about what tremendous partners the Saudis
have been and are.
TOWNSEND: So let's move now to Russia. There's
a whole host of issues between Russia and
Ukraine, but let me start. Nemtsov, an outspoken
opposition figure against Putin, was assassinated
in broad daylight. It just so happened a snowplow
blocked the camera that would've captured
the whole thing. Is there any chance that
this was not perpetrated by Putin and his
allies inside Russia?
CLAPPER: Well, that's, you know, an obvious
theory. There are those—some Russian Kremlin
officials have suggested that we did it just
to create hate and discontent in the political
fabric of Russia. So there is a long tradition
of that sort of thing. You know, to paraphrase
Stalin, when you have a problem, get rid of
the man. No man, no problem. So I don't know.
We don't know. We don't have any unique insight
as to who did this, and I would venture the
history has been we never do find out. Although
I am sure that Putin himself personally is
going to investigate.
(LAUGHTER)
TOWNSEND: So you were asked during your hearing
by Senator McCain, based on the intelligence
assessment, we see the Russians arming their
forces in Eastern Ukraine. Should we, and
what is the discussion within the administration
on arming the Ukrainians?
CLAPPER: Of course that's a policy thing.
But I was kind of prompted, I guess, you know,
what's my own view. By the way, the Russians
are doing more than just providing arms. They
have moved units, particularly last August,
and really reversed the, you know, battlefield
situation there when the Ukrainians were really
moving east and the Russians stepped in and
stopped that.
I was recently in Kiev about a month or so
ago and I was, you know, quite struck with
the intensity with which the Ukrainians look
at this. And so I look at it more as, you
know, I have been an advocate for arming them
with legal defensive weapons, more to bolster
their resolve and bolster their morale that,
you know, we are with them.
Again, this is—I will reiterate now what
I said last Thursday, that this is not company
policy. This is just me, Jimmy Clapper, speaking,
and this is something that is in deliberation
right now among the policy community. It won't
be an intel call.
TOWNSEND: So there is no question Russia has
been persistently aggressive. Crimea, now
Eastern Ukraine. There are those who would
say that there is also intelligence suggesting
further aggression in the former Eastern European
states—Latvia, Estonia. How concerned are
you about that and how likely do you believe
that is?
CLAPPER: Well, first of all I think, you know,
what motivates, what drives Putin, what's
his worldview, and I think he is somewhat
of a throwback to the halcyon days of the
great Russian Empire. That's kind of the way
he looks at things. And so on the 22nd of
February last year, when Yanukovych just kind
of left, suddenly, Ukraine, I think he saw
an opportunity there which he'd been waiting
for, first to take back the Crimea, which,
you know, has always been in his mind a tremendous
injustice. And of course he considers the
collapse of the Soviet Union one of the greatest
geopolitical disasters in the history of the
world.
And so you kind of see where he's coming from.
And particularly with the special relationship
between Russia and Ukraine, which they refer
to as "little Ukraine". And so this is another
occasion not unlike Georgia. The number one
foreign policy goal of Russia is control of
the former Soviet space. So that's what they
did in Georgia and so it is again here in
Ukraine.
NowI do think there is a difference, even
in their mind, with the Baltic states because,
unlike Ukraine of course, they are NATO members.
So you have the article 5 thing, which I think
does serve as a deterrent. That's not to say,
though, that I think the Russians won't be
doing, you know, soft power kinds of things—espionage,
information operations, propaganda, this sort
of thing which you can, you know, look at
Moldova or Transnistria, and they will continue
to do that.
TOWNSEND: So last week the president announced
the establishment of the Cyber Threat Intelligence
Center. It is by my count will be the sixth
cyber center in the government.
CLAPPER: Actually there's more than that..
TOWNSEND: OK. Well, however many there are,
why is this one necessary and what function
does it perform that's not redundant?
CLAPPER: Well, I think for one, cyber pervades
so many aspects of our lives and it pervades
so much of what we do in intelligence these
days. So what this element is intended to
do, and it's very small, you know, it's not
going to be that many people. And what I think
we can do is to bring to bear more integration
within the intelligence community and our
reporting on cyber threats.
And I liken it to what we now do with the
president's daily brief, where we have responsibility
for putting together the ultimate word, if
you will, by integrating the inputs and views
of the entire intelligence community. And
that's our intent with this, our modest intent
with this group is to do a better job of integrating
the intelligence picture with respect to cyber
threats.
So we are in the midst now of—I say we,
my deputy Stephanie O'Sullivan and I—are
in the midst of making a lot of parish calls
among all these groups, all of whom are concerned
and threatened and all that sort of thing,
just to try to allay concerns because the
objectives here, I think, are pretty modest
but I think we can make some value-added contribution
in terms of better job of an integrated threat
picture with respect to cyber.
TOWNSEND: So, can't speak about cyber these
days without talking about the recent Sony
attack. There has been much sort of theorizing
and dispute out there in the media. How confident
are you that it was appropriately attributed
to North Korea?
CLAPPER: Very confident.
TOWNSEND: I want you to share with the group
because you had the distinct honor to go and
get the captives that were released. It's
sort of a fascinating story if you are willing
to share it.
CLAPPER: Well, yes. And coincidentally of
course, the attack occurred against Sony about
a week or two after I was there, so I probably
won't be going back. There had been, you know,
some back and forth with the North Koreans
about, you know, releasing the other two citizens.
We had one, Jeffrey Fowle, was released in
October. The difference here was he was not
yet in the North Korean penal system.
And of course typically the North Koreans
like to secure, if they can, some concessions.
And so there was some back and forth about
a presidential envoy coming to Pyongyang to
secure the release of our two citizens. And
the North Koreans wanted someone who was a
member, a current member of government, and
a member of the National Security Council.
Somehow—I'm not sure where the suggestion
came from, whether it was from them or the
White House, but my name came up, and amazingly,
the North Koreans agreed. I had served in
the Republic of Korea in the early '80s while
I was on active duty as a director of intelligence
for U.S. forces Korea, and kind of followed
developments on the peninsula ever since.
So they, interestingly enough, bought into
my being the envoy. I thought actually the
New York Times had the best explanation of
why the DNI: gruff, blunt, a relic of the
Cold War, ideal for North Korea.
(LAUGHTER)
So I was on a trip, in fact I was in Canada,
and was in Ottawa and I was due to come here
to speak here at CFR and as well do a taping
with Charlie Rose, which I did this morning.
So I'm making up for that now.
Anyway, I got a summons from Susan Rice saying,
you need to hustle back, so I went to a meeting,
flew back from Ottawa early, joined the meeting
at the White House in which we were discussing
things like don't bow, don't take flowers,
don't smile, you know. Lots of useful policy
things like that.
(LAUGHTER)
Anyway, I ran home and repacked my bag and
back out to Andrews and left about 2 o'clock—this
is November 4th, I think, and we had some
airplane challenges on the way out there.
And finally arrived on the night of November
7th in Pyongyang and went immediately into
dialogue with the North Koreans.
I was met by a political four-star, General
Kim who is a minister of state security. And
so we had this long slow roll in a limo from
Sunan airport downtown to Pyongyang to the
state guesthouse. And we immediately began
deploying each other's talking points in the
car. I immediately got a little hinky about
I wasn't getting any assurances that we were
going to get our two citizens back.
So they dropped us at the state guesthouse,
which is a very nice place, and then we were
met by the official who touted himself as
my counterpart. He was another General Kim,
a military four-star Kim who is director of
what's called a Reconnaissance General Bureau,
which is an amalgam between their intelligence
and special forces.
Then back in the limo back in downtown Pyongyang
to a restaurant, a private restaurant which
interestingly enough was over a bowling alley.
In fact I remember, I was trying to make light
conversation—which they don't do—"oh,
people in the DPRK bowl?" and he wasn't having
it.
(LAUGHTER)
Anyway, we went to the restaurant and it was
very nice, and having served in Korea and
developed a liking for Korean food, and this
marvelous twelve-course meal and the best
kimchee I've ever eaten in my life was in
North Korea. Unfortunately, it wasn't a very
enjoyable because—pretty terseconversation,
pretty tense and a lot of arguing, you know,
pointing at each other's chest and that sort
of thing.
TOWNSEND: Do we think that's why you got stuck
withthe check?
CLAPPER: They don't like us. They like our
money, you know, I guess. Anyway, so at the
end of the evening I did have a letter from
the president, which didn't say a great deal
other than just, you know, officially authenticating
me as his representative and, you know, it
would be viewed by the U.S. government as
a positive gesture if they released our two
citizens.
Since they didn't hand me a schedule or agenda
or anything when I got there, we deployed
the letter with the RGB director, and back
to the state guesthouse. The next day we just
kind of hung out, waiting around for them
to do something. We had a doctor with us and
I did ask if the doctor could visit the two
citizens, which they did agree to, although
instructed the doctor not to say anything
to either of our citizens about the possibility
of them being released.
So about 11 o'clock we're just hanging out,
and it's not like you can call a cab or something
and drive around. This representative of the
minister of state security came to the state
guesthouse and informed us that I had been
demoted, that they no longer considered me
a presidential envoy, since I was there simply
to, you know, gain the release of our two
criminals. Moreover, they could not any longer
guarantee the safety and security of me or
my small party. Thanks.
So what do you do when you're killing time?
So we had lunch. Hung around, and hung around.
About 3 o'clock, 3:15 in the afternoon, the
same gentleman came back and said we hadtwenty
minutes to pack up, check out and get out
of here, we're leaving. So we pile in the
vehicles. Took us downtown to the Koryo hotel,
which is a pretty nice hotel in Pyongyang.
Escorted us upstairs to a room about half
the size of this room and in the middle of
the room was a racetrack-shaped table.
On one side were three or four North Korean
officials who were, I found out later, representatives
of the North Korean prosecutor's office. On
the other side were three or four chairs for
me and a couple of people with me. So we were
just sitting there. It seemed endless but
it was probably onlytwenty minutes, and
no one is saying anything, can hear a pin
drop, and they're staring at us and we are
staring at them.
And that's the first time I actually saw our
two citizens, Bae and Miller, who were in
their prison garb. So we didn't talk to them
or anything. And then finally the door opens
and in enters the aforementioned minister
of state security, the gentleman that had
met me the night before. We all stand up like
he's a judge or something and he comes in
and they read a proclamation, which included
a litany of the heinous crimes that our two
citizens had rendered and performed, and the
generosity of the DPRK government for allowing—that
they would grant amnesty at the request of
the president.
Of course that was translated and at the end
of it Minister Kim turned to me and said,
"well, I hope we can have more dialogue in
the future but not about your criminals".
And I said thanks. And they all walked out
with our guys and they changed clothes in
the hotel and out to the airport and we left.
And I must say—we had to stop at several
places on the way back but got to McChord
Air Force Base about 8:30Saturday night,
the 8th, I guess it was. And I went up in
the cockpit and just watched the family reunions,
which was actually gratifying and very emotional
to watch that. And right after that got a
call from the president thanking me and my
team for a successful mission. So had a gin
and tonic and went to bed for a while. That
was it.
(LAUGHTER)
TOWNSEND: So I've got two more quick questions
about cyber and then I'm going to open it
up to the members. One, is it in your mind
possible that North Korea could have pulled
off the Sony cyber attack without the help
of either Iran or Russia or China or some
other state power?
CLAPPER: Oh, yes. They are not at the same
level of sophistication and capability as,
say, the top tier, which means Russia and
China, but they engage in cyber exploitation,
et cetera, you know, constantly againstthe
Republic ofKorea.
So they are astute at this. They have a whole
infrastructure, much of which is under the
auspices of the aforementioned Reconnaissance
General Bureau and my good friend General
Kim. So they are quite capable.
TOWNSEND: Let me ask you. We've seen numerous
public reports about DDoS, dedicated denial
of service, attacks against U.S. financial
institutions. What is the likelihood in your
judgment, based on the intelligence, of a
Sony or Aramco-type of destructive attack
against U.S. financial interests?
CLAPPER: I spoke to that in my oral statement,
that the situation we are in in cyber is—I
think we attach less likelihood to the notion
of a, you know, cyber Armageddon. That's not
to say it's impossible. Sure, it is possible,
but less likely.
Instead what we are faced with is this sort
of insidious growth where cyber actors do
increasingly more nefarious things in kind
of a gradual incremental way. So it's not
going to be some dramatic thing but rather
a gradual increase.
So last year, as I pointed out, was the first
time we had destructive cyber attacks on our
soil, first with the Las Vegas casino Sands
Corporation, and then of course with the Sony
attack. If you go back and sort of trace the
trendlines in cyber, phishing, DDoS, and then—so
what's next? Well, deletion or manipulation,
which of course affects the integrity of the
data, is probably next.
TOWNSEND: Pretty scary stuff. OK. At this
time I would like to invite members to join
our conversation with questions. A reminder
this meeting is on the record. Wait for the
microphone, speak directly into it, please
stand and then state your name and affiliation.
Please limit yourself to one question and
keep it concise to allow as many members as
possible to speak. Let's start here.
QUESTION: Thank you. Director, my name is
Roland Paul, I'm a lawyer, I've been in government
a couple of times. Absolutely thrilling story
about your trip to North Korea, I might add.My
question relates to Syria. According to the
press there are 40,000 to 80,000 Syrian rebels
who are not affiliated with ISIL or al-Nusra.
Could you correct that order of magnitude,
and also tell us what might be the U.S. government
relationship with those groups?
CLAPPER: Well, first of all, these numbers
and estimates get tossed around quite a bit.
I was asked about that during my hearing with
the Senate Armed Services Committee. So I
think the first thing is, just to tell you
flat out, we do not have Census Bureau door-to-door
survey fidelity on these groups. I wish we
did but we don't.
There are by one estimate rendered last year,
some 1,600 of these opposition groups. So
determining their size and capability and,
importantly, their ideological or political
leanings is very, very difficult. So all of
these numbers that you hear, we do our best
from a variety of sources to assess the composition
of these groups and their leanings. But this
is a very, very difficult thing to do.
So there are some portion of our oppositions
who are regarded as moderate. Moderate these
days is increasingly becoming anyone who's
not affiliated with ISIL. And so, you know,
we are attempting to engage with them, and
that's the whole point of the train and equip
proposal—project that the Department of
Defense is gearing up for, is to vet, recruit
and train and equip oppositions in sufficient
size and capability to actually make a military
difference.
And so one of our challenges is, again, the
recruiting and vetting part. So we picked
people that not only are moderate, whatever
that is, but also we have to be sensitive
to complying with the international rules
of law, which in this environment is a pretty
tough order.
So this is a very, very complex situation
in Syria, compounded by the fact that we are
actually not there, which is very different
than the situation we have in Iraq, where
we are there. And so from an intelligence
perspective and for our ability to exert leverage
and influence, it's much, much easier in Iraq
than it is in Syria. That's a long-winded
answer to your question but it's a tough one.
QUESTION: Ken Roth, from Human Rights Watch.
I'd like to follow up on Iraq. I think at
the policy level there's broad recognition
that the Shia militia and the abuses and the
sectarian way in which they operated was a
big reason why so many of the Sunni tribes
would join with the U.S. to defeat al-Qaeda
in Iraq, either by neutral or actually joining
with ISIS because they were so fearful of
the Shia militia. And that was part of why
Maliki's departure was orchestrated.
Today the Human Rights Watch people on the
ground still find the Shia militia engaging
in what you might call ethnic cleansing as
they take various Sunni villages. My question
to you is, what are the prospects of a nonsectarian
and rights-respecting Iraqi military emerging?
When do you see that happening so that Iraq
isn't dependent on the Shia militia?
CLAPPER: Well, I think you have to start from
the premise that Iraq is inherently sectarian.
That's just the nature of the country. The
country of Iraq is somewhat of an artificial
creation going back to colonial days. And
so you have the Kurds and then the Sunnis
in the north predominantly and Shias in the
south.
And you're quite right. The reason that ISIL
was so successful, yes, it had to do with
their capabilities and prowess on the battlefield,
but they were dealing with a receptive constituency
in northern Iraq because of the intense hatred
of the Maliki government, which of course
is imposing the Shia view on them.
And so the challenge for Abadi, who, you know,
does I think recognize what he has to do in
terms of more inclusiveness of the Sunnis,
because I really don't think there's any way
of reversing or changing the picture fundamentally
in Iraq unless the Sunnis are included, and
unless that's done in a way that's compelling
and convincing to them, and so far that's
been a struggle. Abadi has a challenge, the
political challenge of trying to keep his
Shia base in line with him and supportive
of him. So he has got a very difficult balancing
act.
Then you have the complication of the Iranians,
who want a Shia-friendly government in Baghdad
that they feel they can influence because
it's right next door to them. So he has a
confluence here of a whole bunch of competing
and conflicting forces that he has to deal
with. And it is a very tough issue. But certainly
he, I think, is in a better position to do
that than certainly his predecessor.
QUESTION: Bettye Musham, Duke Islamic Studies
Center founder. Have you had any conversations
or concerns about the Saudi's funding all
of these madrassas which are promoting the
Wahhabi doctrine of conservatism? And I know
in Turkey there are over 500 of them over
a period of time.
CLAPPER: That is a concern, and I think there
is change afoot in the Mideast. It's not going
to occur overnight, but I think, you know,
these brutalities, publicized brutalities
by ISIL, beheadings and immolations and the
like, have really had a galvanizing effect,
even in the Mideast. And so I think it is
bringing about a change.
One thing we see is the donations to extremist
groups from many of these countries, donors
in the countries, are declining. Some of that
is through government activity, government
oversight and with our help. But in the end
this is about—I hate to use a cliche from
my war, southeast Asia, but it is about the
hearts and minds here.
And ultimately that is what's going to make
a difference here, is the narrative or counter
narrative, starting with education. And so
I think you are quite right to highlight that.
I do think, though, that there is a change
afoot, but it is not going to happen by close
of business next Friday.
TOWNSEND: Director Clapper, can you just give
us a sense of scale? You said that the donations
from the Gulf countries are declining. I'm
not asking for precise numbers off the top
of your head but give us an order of magnitude.
CLAPPER: I really can't do that because it
varies from place to place and it varies from
who they are donating to and all this sort
of thing. I will just make the statement in
general, there has been a big decline. The
amount of donations that ISIL got was a very,
very—less than 1 percent of their total
revenue from last year. I can say that.
QUESTION: In recent days the government reauthorized
the telephone metadata collection program
through June 1st, when there is the sunset
date obviously of section 215 of the Patriot
Act. What do you want to see happen after
that?
CLAPPER: Well, what we've agreed to, Attorney
General Eric Holder and I last September signed
a letter saying that we supported the notion
of moving the retention of the data to providers,
in a bill that actually came out of the Senate
from Senator Leahy. So we signed up to that.
I think that's the only thing that's realistic
if we are going to have this at all.
You know, in the end, the Congress giveth
and the Congress taketh away. So if the Congress
in its wisdom decides that the candle isn't
worththe flame, the juice isn't worththe
squeeze, whatever metaphor you want to use,
that's fine. And the intelligence community
will do all we can within the law to do what
we can to protect the country.
But, I have to say that, you know, every time
we lose another tool in our toolkit, you know,
it raises the risk. If that tool is taken
away from us, 215, and some untoward incident
happens which could have been thwarted had
we had it, I just hope that everyone involved
in that decision assumes responsibility. And
it not be blamed, if we have another failure,
exclusively on the intelligence community.
QUESTION: And just to be clear, with the private
providers maintaining that data, do you feel
you've lost an important tool?
CLAPPER: Not necessarily. It will depend,
though, on, for one, retention period. I think
given the attitude today with providers, they
will probably do all they can to minimize
the retention period, which of course from
our standpoint lessens the utility of the
data because you do need some—and we can
prove this statistically—you do need some
historical data in order to discern a pattern.
And again, you know, 215 to me is much like
my fire insurance policy. You know, my house
has never burned down but every year I buy
fire insurance just
in case.
QUESTION: Celia Mendoza, Voice of America.
You mentioned that there is a lot of threats
that we have to be aware of. Venezuela right
now is in a very dire situation and they have
close relationships with Iran, with Syria,
as well as with Russia. How do you see the
relationship between the United States and
the intelligence you are gathering, especially
with all the accusations made by the government
of Nicolas Maduro against the United States?
CLAPPER: Well, Venezuela is going through
a difficult time right now, for lots of reasons.
I think economically obviously the price of
oil has had, because of their disproportionate
dependence on oil revenue, mostly from us,
that's had an impact on their economy. President
Maduro, maybe not the most astute head of
state, I'll put it that way, is having trouble
coping with this because of the economic stresses
it's putting on his country. And of course
what he's most concerned about is people turning
out in the streets, which would be potentially
a real threat
to them.
QUESTION: Sarah Leah Whitson at Human Rights
Watch. I wanted to ask you some more about
the metanarrative, and in particular the extent
to which you think the U.S. is really best
placed to take on a metanarrative that will
appeal to people who possibly support Islamist
extremist politics. And also about the metanarrative
of some of the allies in the anti-ISIS coalition,
like Saudi Arabia, which models a lot of the
behavior, like beheadings and jailing and
flogging of journalists that ISIS and al-Qaeda
actually copy.
And I wonder whether there has been any effort
to influence the metanarrative of the important
partner, Saudi Arabia.
CLAPPER: Well, of course. We have, and I think
the question raises a good point about the
extent to which we, the United States, canlead
a narrative, given the general lack of popularity
of the United States in many of these countries.
I was quite struck with the interview I saw
yesterday of King Abdullah of Jordan, who
I have great respect for. And I think he said
some things worth considering, worth thinking
about, which is essentially "this is kind
of our thing. This is something we have to
do".
And I don't think he intended it in just a
military context, but in the context of getting
ahead of or countering the larger narrative
here. And you know, we are doing this in all
kinds of ways to try to counter the narrative
but I think in the end, you know, our ability
to do that and to really influence change
in attitudes and change in worldview is only
going to come about when the people there
themselves do that.
QUESTION: Paula DiPerna, NTR Foundation. Thank
you very much for your service. And the question
is, with—beyond the sort of local assets,
people who obviously you have to remunerate,
can you speak to the degree to which intelligence
gathering has been privatized, outsourced,
contracted out, both in terms of percentage
and dollar value?
CLAPPER: Well, actually it's declined. At
least as a formal part of the intelligence
community, that which we've contracted out
or hired contractors has declined by 40 percent
since 2007, and in our 2016 submission it
is going to go down more. So we are less and
less dependent on contractors.
This of course is the classical historical
cycle that we go through in the intelligence
community, where the pendulum is swinging
back from the mushrooming that we did right
after 9/11, where the intelligence community,
which had been shrinking for five years, suddenly
expanded. And the fast way to do that, of
course, is to hire a lot of contractors, which
we did.
So now that our funding is going down, and
in the interest of trying to protect our government
workforce, which I feel very strongly about
protecting these great people, young people
that we've brought on since 9/11, so we are
peeling off contractors, so it's actually
declining.
QUESTION: Jeff Laurenti. I wonder, Mr. Director,
if you could comment on the love triangle
between American, Afghan and Pakistani intelligence
as the United States is disengaging. How reliable
is the Afghan intelligence network in terms
of its penetration of the Taliban? Do you
see any signs that the Taliban are beginning
to feel demoralization? And how genuine is
the ISI in Pakistan's seeming, slow-creep
embrace of normal relations with the Afghan
government?
CLAPPER: Well, those are a great bunch of
questions there. I start this from the premise
that every country, no matter who it is—and
I have dealt with a lot of them from an intelligence
perspective—they start from the premise
of what is in their national interest. That
may or may not comport with what we like,
necessarily. And so we have to recognize the
reality of how things are in the world.
So in the case of the Pakistanis, penultimately
what motivates their policies, to include
their conduct of intelligence, is what they
consider their existential threat, which is
India. And so that governs a lot of what they
do.
Now I will tell you, in line with what I said
earlier about the public savagery and brutality
of ISIL, the attack on the Pakistani army
school in Peshawar had a galvanizing impact
on public opinion in Pakistan. And that in
turn of course influences the government and
influences ISI.
You know, we had a very low point in our relations
with Pakistan and, you know, as a result of
the Abbottabad raid in May of 2011, and since
then it has gradually come up. I think the
Pakistanis realize the impact of when we depart
from Afghanistan and that they need to be
more active and viable partner, and they are.
There has been a great improvement in their
approach and their cooperation with us and
their openness. But there are certain things
that they probably fundamentally are not going
to change, again because of what drives them.
With respect to Afghanistan, I think the intelligence
services there, particularly the national
one, is good and getting better. We've spent
a lot of time and effort at enhancing their
capabilities, but they too are going to behave
in what they believe are their best interests.
I might say with respect to Afghanistan that
I think I would commend to you history. In
our last national intelligence estimate we
devoted an annex to the Soviet experience.
And the lesson learned here is that when they
left in 1989—they continued very robust
financial support to the Afghan government
to the tune of $3 [billion] to $6 billion
a year normalized I think in 2011 dollars.
When they left, when that support stopped
on the 31st of December, 1991, about four
months later the government of Afghanistan
collapsed.
So the big lesson here is not so much, you
know, the pace of our drawdown. It's what
happens afterwards in terms of external donors'
financial support which the Afghan government
is so highly dependent on.
TOWNSEND: Director Clapper, I think that it
is 2 o'clock and I want to be respectful of
your time. I want to thank you for being here
with us, and just on a personal note, let
me thank you for your friendship, your mentorship,
and for your public service.
CLAPPER: May I say one last thing. It is a
great honor for me to be here in this series
in light of who it was named after. And the
family is here today, and I just want to say
they epitomize, and Ken did, the spirit of
so many people who serve in the intelligence
community today who came to the intelligence
community—came back to the intelligence
community, as I did, after 9/11.
And so I do want to take note of Ken and his
tremendous legacy, and it is an honor to be
here in a series named after him. So thanks.
(APPLAUSE)
END